whoa gene that's how Keanu Reaves
Wolverine hey gene that's my Christopher
walk oh I got it guys we're gonna watch
the day from the cosmic wonder how
Marvel's x-men will enter the MCU
everything we know he has such good
sources and he's been right many a times
go follow his channel I'll tell you why
you might have noticed on our community
page you put her to poll recently asking
who do you think should be the next
Wolverine and that's because we are
filming tomorrow with the cosmic wonder
we're gonna finally be doing a collab
together talking about our thoughts
under the next wolverine should be you
can go vote over at our community page
that poll is still up and also wanted to
mention with this quarantine situation
going on then posting a hell of a lot on
stardust 30-second reviews for films TV
shows and or trailers literally been
catching up on so many different shows
it would be worth your time the whole
thing is free to download free to use
free for you to upload your own videos
as well do it right when this video is
done how's it going everybody it's Lorne
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things relating to Marvel and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and today
we're going to be talking about
something that everybody has been
waiting for for a very long time the
humans introduction into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now ever since Disney
acquired the rights back to the Fox
characters such as the x-men Fantastic
Four Deadpool and etc everybody has been
wondering exactly how long is it going
to take for the x-men to enter the MCU
too much and although we all thought
that it would be quite some time before
we see the x-men in the MCU because
Marvel would want to take their time and
introducing their characters and coming
up with their plan Kevin Feige name
dropped them at San Diego Comic Con
implying that they are going to be
coming sooner than later now considering
the fact that Marvel hasn't really said
much about the x-men coming to the MCU
we actually know a lot about their plan
of what they want to do with them
including how they are going to
introduce them in fact it may surprise
you on just how similar their
introduction to the MCU could be to the
Avengers eventually going on to come
together
team and have an x-men film so in this
video I'll talk about everything we know
so far about the x-men coming to the MCU
including how they're going to be
introduced which x-men are expected to
be introduced when they're expected to
enter the MCU and some leaks and reports
that we have so far
about the x-men joining some of our
current heroes and upcoming movies soon
okay new be sure to subscribe to stay up
to date on all Marvel related content
and to enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 more giveaway
details at the end of this video so as
I'm sure most people know Disney and
Marvel Studios since they are owned by
Disney have finally and officially
acquired the rights back to the Fox
owned Marvel characters these include
the entirety of the x-men the Fantastic
Four
Deadpool Galactus Doctor Doom and more
and so now the question is how is Marvel
going to introduce these characters that
have already been on the big screen
before under Fox
well for starters Marvel wants their
x-men in the MCU to be very different
than the Fox x-men and they're not going
to just come out and do an x-men film
like Fox did there has to be a
noticeable difference between the MCU
version of the x-men and the Fox's
version of the x-men and some time has
to pass before a big x-men film and this
is so people don't confuse the two
franchises enough time has to pass to
where people don't think the MCU version
of the x-men is tying in to the Fox
version somehow fair it's a lot harder
for the x-men because the Fantastic Four
are pretty easy it's one team of atom
and that you can use so the Fantastic
Four is relatively easy to do as long as
enough time passes and Fantastic Four
film was some time ago so enough time is
probably and not to mention the last
film didn't tie into the original to
Fantastic Four film so the continuity
isn't really a problem so based off in
that and based off of what Kevin Feige
has said in some interviews we know that
Marvel is going to introduce their MCU
x-men and FC
and this in itself one prize they could
do solo films for new x-men coming to
the MCU or they could tie them into
other films with other heroes for
example oh right like yeah that'd be a
freighter every news report says that
rogue is going to be in Captain Marvel -
and that rogue is going to be the main
villain Road is a classic Captain Marvel
villain and in the film of course you
would be a mutant but the film is still
going to be Captain Marvel - it's not
going to be an x-men film or a film
about mutants whatsoever but they don't
and there should be the villain almost
like they're not really making that big
of a deal about it they're just going to
gradually introduce them and build them
up we then have another report from
Mikey Sutton that states that the
Illuminati is going to be introduced and
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness now in the original Illuminati
team from the comics there are several
mutants a part of the team and not to
mention mr. fantastic of the Fantastic
Four and one of the main leaders is
Professor Xavier
now Professor Xavier is an x-men that
everybody knows signature wheelchair
signature x-head so you could introduce
Professor X into the MCU at any point in
time and people will go
that's Professor Xavier the x-men are
coming again this is going to be during
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness it's not very experienced x-men
film this is an approach that Marvel is
going to take to introduce some of these
x-men introduce them in other films
without making that big of a deal about
it another example is Black Widow it's
highly believed that we could see the
very first mutant in the MCU as early on
as they debut of black I actually really
like that idea
Roger will be in the movie and although
they may not come out and state that he
is a mutant he definitely is Oliver
Richards aka the Dutch giant posted on
Instagram before editing his post
stating that he was going to be playing
as a major he then edited his post to
make it not so obvious but again this is
part of Marvel's plan to mention that
gives me plus Disney Plus is an
excellent platform that Marvel could use
to introduce many different mutants to
the MCU because all of the Disney Plus
shows are in the MCU and in fact most of
the characters that get introduced in
Disney Plus will most likely be on the
big screen during some team-up now
another thing to note about the
introduction of the x-men is something
that Kevin Feige basically confirmed
himself in an interview
and that is we're not going to get the
typical well-known mutants in the MCU
yes we of course are going to get some
main ones like Professor Xavier but we
are going to see a bunch of other ones
that haven't really gotten screen time
in any of the films when speaking loved
that in the MCU and introducing them
Kevin Feige said in an interview it's
not just the marquee names you know
there are hundreds of names on those
documents on those agreements the fact
that Marvel is now as close as we may
ever be to having access to all of the
characters is something I've been
dreaming about for my almost 20 years at
Marvel it's very exciting
so that's like it'd be a great subtle
dill - it can expect to see some but
haven't really gotten any screen time in
the movies and of course you going over
any MCU and of course there are many
diverse characters to choose from in the
comics but here's why introduced perfect
dynamic time either in solo films on
Disney Plus or in other MCU movies is a
really good thing and that is they're
basically copying the way that they
introduced the Avengers when the MCU
started beta and just come out with an
Avengers film would it have been popular
and successful if they just did that of
course but would it have been as popular
and as successful no the reason why the
Avengers worked so well is because Kevin
Feige and Marvel Studios introduced the
individual Avengers one at a time in
their own solo films we got to know each
character before they were a team and
watch them go on their own this is great
my mind is spirally x-men especially the
ones that go on to become true x-men for
Charles Xavier we're going to see who
they were before and eventually Charles
Xavier will recruit them and bring them
to his school and that's when we will
have our x-men film it'll be done just
like how they did the Avengers they'll
introduce Iron Man Captain America Thor
the Hulk
Black Widow Hawkeye and then have them
all come together as a very brought them
together in the film and it's most
likely that somebody like Charles Xavier
will bring the mutants together in the
x-men Co have solo movies for people
like Wolverine storm Cyclops and of
course characters that Oh origin movie
of wolves array be huge and satisfying
because we've watched each individual
character be built up over time now as
far as
they are coming to the MCU it's not as
long as you may think again Kevin Feige
mentioned the mutants at San Diego
comic-con and he said that they have all
of phase 5 already planned out and he
was going to reveal phase 5 but he
thought that everything in phase 4 was
already enough to talk about but he made
it a specific point at the end of SDCC
to save mutants Fantastic Four and blade
he would not name dropped these if they
were not coming soon now a couple of
months ago it was revealed that Patrick
Stewart who of course played a Professor
Xavier the original Professor X met with
Kevin Feige about Professor X Patrick
Stewart revealed this in an interview
when he said I met with Kevin Feige a
couple of months ago and we had long
long conversation and there have been
moves and suggestions when I universe ty
and Xavier this is straight from Patrick
Stewart's mouth Wyatt is 100% confirmed
that this happened and he said that as
far as Charles Xavier is concerned Kevin
Feige has made moves and suggestions so
that officially confirms that plans for
the x-men in the MCU are already
underway
whether that's introducing one of them
or many of them in the upcoming future
we are going to see them in the MCU soon
and the film that is most likely going
to set them up is the Eternals now the e
tournaments are almost an away mutants
the Eternals were created by the
Celestials and they are described as an
offshoot of the evolutionary process
that created sentient life on earth in
the comics a million years ago from
where we stand today in the MCU the
Celestials went to earth and they did
experiments on the early humans the
products of these experiments were the
Celestials and their counterparts the
deviants now it's widely speculated that
in the MCU there could be another
byproduct of the celestial experiments
and they could be mutants the mutants
and the MC use X gene could come from
experiments done years and years and
years before by the Celestials it's also
I love that in the MCU the Celestials
are not allowed to have kids well some
of them most likely did and the
offsprings of those kids and so on and
so forth could be the x-men
so the mutants are most likely going to
arrive in the MCU as early on as phase 4
maybe even as early on as Marvel Studios
as Black Widow with the introduction of
Ursa Major
so the x-men are coming soon they're
going to
come one at a time and be picked up just
like hi ever of in everything I'm here
in x-men film what do you think about
this plan would you like the x-men to be
introduced all at one time in their very
own film or would you like them to be
built up just like the Avengers were let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below and let me know
which x-men you would like to see enter
the MCU first answer you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 and picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof boom
great video dude oh man so much to talk
about so I heard a topic recently
brought up I think it was on the John
Campea show actually is the MC use best
days behind them now that you know
endgame has already come out I don't
think it is because once we start
getting more solidified on-screen
moments of mutants coming into the play
I feel like that's gonna give us a lot
more to look forward to and a lot more
to get truly excited about Fantastic
Four included I think it's really cool
that the first few phases of the MCU
didn't have the x-men world and
Fantastic Four yet it was such a
monumental success and really change
cinema landscape now I can only imagine
what they'll be doing with the
accessibility to mutants and x-men and I
do love everything I'm hearing here if
you guys who saw our buddy did a video
where new rockstars noticed us in that
video I pitched my version my idea that
I've had of how I would personally
introduce the mutant I don't want to
just repeat that I want to just go off
of what's being presented in this video
because I didn't think about the idea
presenting them one at a time kind of
like the Avengers instead though what
you'd get is having a mutant here a
mutant there appearing in a supporting
role and then you could transition to
doing solo films of them then eventually
get your x-men movie where Professor X
is kind of the symbolic version of what
Nick Fury has been for the Avengers I
think that idea sounds significantly
cooler John thoughts I hundred percent
agree I mean I think that leaves you
open to just so many options I think
it's fortunate yeah that Marvel had to
really focus on streamlining one thing
before getting access to all of these
other keys to these other kingdoms yeah
if you took that route of introducing
them like a Hawkeye or like a Black
Widow as supporting characters or even
as villains at the outset or something
like that build it up there's just so
much you can do and for me I always hope
that when the x-men start to spiral off
into their own x-men adventures I would
hope that maybe those films can take a
slightly different tone than the greater
MCU perhaps in a different scope I just
think there's so many chances and also I
loved what he was talking about them
wanting to bring in the lesser-known
x-men because I feel like the movies
we've got up until now have given us a
lot of characters but the main ones we
always focus on hang with the most or
some of the flagships and I feel like at
a certain point there's a lot of okay
that guy showed up cool you want to see
him on screen here he is for two seconds
this is a nice chance to also do some
service to characters who have shown up
but haven't had their day right right I
think what Feige is actually attempting
to do right now is something I've wanted
to see done more of what's kind of
happening with the spider-man universe
every compact character that has his own
you know solo run pretty much has his
own universe now yes we have the MCU but
every one of these characters and
especially the x-men lend themselves to
their own universe and I think with
having the Disney Plus shows and while
we're connecting all these different
characters and stuff I think what he's
really doing is is really making that
universe trickle down it's a more little
universes with all these characters I
like the idea of having an x-men
universe that does fully tie-in to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and I like the
idea of these like sideway entrances
into the x-men where we might not even
see it coming
or it might not be fully on the nose
let's say in Black Widow this character
is there it is real but they don't call
him a mutant in it but down the road we
discover oh that seed was planted
already way back when with black widow
or the mutant same thing with Eternals
then maybe they might have a little drop
of the word mutants and maybe they don't
or maybe we see his character yes
something like that where it's so subtle
but they are slowly like they planting
the seed and they're slowly letting that
flower bloom and then eventually you get
like supporting characters in these
movies Rogan Captain Marvel - and they
start getting standalone films I've been
saying for years that if they're gonna
do Wolverine over again why not attempt
it with
another origin tale because x-men
origins Wolverine is one of the most
panned films it's such a bad film and I
think it's so damn boring too and he
deserves a great origin film I love the
mystery with his journey of you know
with the amnesia and all that if there's
one of these origin tales that deserves
a remake it's Wolverine he said well I
love the idea of focusing more on the
smaller characters yes introducing your
Professor X I think that's a great call
if you're gonna do Wolverine again
absolutely redo the origin movie of that
and I feel like that'd be a great way to
reintroduce a new Wolverine as well as
opposed to strictly comparing him to
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine yeah which
makes me curious about the fact that
they had such long conversations with
Patrick Stewart partly because he
brought up a good point at the beginning
of the video they've had the Reno of
Dark Phoenix New Mutants is still
flailing out in the breeze right now so
they want to distance themselves from
the previous films I would imagine then
that makes me wonder are they talking to
Patrick Stewart to do some kind of
alternate universe thing or is it just
that he is so synonymous with that role
that they're just like I will bring you
over to recast everyone else I imagine
it's probably a universe time that
they're opening up these portals with
multiverse of madness Swan division
you'll want to get Patrick Stewart and
there's that way to kind of hand it off
again or something like that and I'm
gonna be opposed to that I think that'd
be really cool cosmic Wonder was talking
about diversity in this video Kevin
Feige is a lot more adamant about
getting a lot more representation in the
film's x-men is the perfect way to do it
this is the way x-men dealt so much that
the main underlying dealt with racism
alike that was such a big theme so if
you're gonna get exceptionally more
diversity where it doesn't feel like
ham-fisted or or on-the-nose x-men is
the most natural way to go down that
path this actually got me more excited
for it than ever before they talked
about introducing characters on the
Disney Plus shows to go into the movies
but would you prefer ultimately an x-men
film or like an x-men TV series I mean
we have the animated series but to have
a live-action with like full Marvel
Studios production you know I think what
they'll probably do is have some mutants
who have their own series even though
x-men is like one thing I made it so
special were its allegories and thematic
explorations I think
we're gonna want to see big screen
expand I wanna see the debut of that so
I think we'll have like mutants I think
at the end of the day we'll probably get
them on the big screen which is which is
why I personally want to I want to see
them clash worlds yeah with the bigger
MCU films and stuff I think that's what
we've all truly been itching for I think
you got to satisfy that itch Drew
Goddard now then yeah look a good
ensemble guy subscribe to the cosmic
wonder to keep a look out for that video
we'll be talking about our Wolverine fan
casting talking about the most voted
ones that you guys put on the community
page so go over there as soon as you can
subscribe to the rail rejects click that
notification belt again notified never
got a new YouTube video up last but not
least let's end this with a Mikael
Linden I wrote you a story based on the
first time we ever met
I first met Mikael while working outside
the Casino Royale he gave me a letter
marked From Russia With Love on the
front it read for your eyes only oh no I
thought what could it be an odd job
orders from Her Majesty's Secret Service
I took a Quantum of Solace as I opened
the letter but all I saw inside was a
Spectre a view to a kill the building
was set to blow felled and it shook the
living daylights out of me
I knew Mikael had always been the live
and let die type but she only lived
twice and I was determined to die
another day should I choose to accept
this mission I began but before more
words could come I felt something slide
into my hand it was Mikhail's license to
kill this left me shaken not stirred as
my brain began to whirl don't be an
octopus II he proclaimed the world is
not enough Tomorrow Never Dies and I've
got no time to die just yet he pressed
his gold finger against my quivering
jaws never will I say never again I
thought to myself sky falls the limit
said he putting on his windbreaker once
we get to the moon I'm sure you'll make
a great
Moonraker and that's the story of my
Thunder ball The Spy Who Loved me my
diamond forever my man with the golden
gun
michail from patreon I don't know is
there some vector